if you like
nature
if you like grass
and fresh air
this may not be the place for you
[Music]
hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today we're talking about my first
month in los angeles so i moved to la uh
july
ish
plus or minus a day and a half so i
moved yeah pretty much exactly a month
ago i moved from the midwest however
i've kind of grown up in many different
locations i spent my childhood in new
york city then spent my adolescence to
early adulthood in the midwest and then
i have had a few months where i've lived
again in new york city and whatnot and
so i've had different experiences
with yeah city versus suburban versus
xyz and la is very much a place where
you can have either and they can be very
very opposite from one another and so i
live in downtown los angeles like right
in the smack bat of downtown and
oh okay i'm going to break this
reflection up into multiple different
buckets i'll go into first impression
slash observations
go into people go into dating and dating
life here and just general activities
and vibes and all of that and so one of
the very first observations i made here
is it's not very crowded here when i
think of downtown or when i thought of
downtown la i kind of thought of like
new york manhattan-ish
but obviously not as large but that kind
of
population may be cut in half but it's
not even like .01 of that i don't know
if this is because of the parent-teacher
conference that's been going on for the
last 2000 years or if this is just the
norm i think that's also something i'll
say a lot that i don't know if this is
the panda bear or if it's just the norm
and so yeah there's really not many
people
around walking around and i don't have a
car here yet i haven't shipped my car
over and so i've been walking a lot here
so i feel like i've gotten to experience
a lot of downtown from morning to
afternoon tonight from weekdays to
weekends oh my gosh i just had the
biggest coughing fit so if you see me
cry mind your business but yeah from
weekdays to week ends i've really just
explored and seen a lot of what there is
to see i feel like and yeah there's not
really many people around if there are
people everyone really just minds their
own business which is very different
from new york because people in new york
are all up in your business like they
are physically just all up in here or
just in terms of wording and all of
these things they're very vocal but no
people here are very much mind your own
business and carry on and so i really do
appreciate that but if you're thinking
about moving to downtown l.a versus
another place what i will say off the
bat is if you like
nature
if you like grass
and fresh air
this may not be the place for you
i
wish and it sounds so obvious but i wish
someone had said this to me because i do
like fresh air i do love walks in the
park in my last apartment before i moved
i would take every single day take two
hours to walk at this large huge park
and lake just two blocks away from me
and that would be the best thing of the
best part of my day i didn't realize
how much i would miss that because i
knew i appreciated that because again it
would be
my favorite part of the day but i didn't
know how much not having that would
affect me basically
and
it's fine there's no park really but not
even fresh air
or anything that's i it's things you
don't really think about
at least okay i didn't think about it
when i was making the decision to move
and so i'm like huh okay okay so new
smells we're gonna have to
get accustomed to that that and also
like the parks i was like okay now that
has to be a park around here and so i
looked on google maps and i was like oh
there's a park just like a few blocks
away walk there it is pretty much all
concrete all concrete it was a concrete
park i was like okay y'all this is not a
park this is a i don't even know a
concert hall this is a
monumental site this is i don't know
this is not a park and so that was very
disappointing but at least i got to
stretch my legs and have a walk in
general but anyway yes if you appreciate
nature
without having to take an excursion out
of where you live to experience it this
may not be the place for you but if you
don't mind taking you know a drive to
griffith park or to glendale or to santa
monica then okay like this you will be
fine here probably because yeah you
don't mind taking that extra step to get
those things i'm gonna make sure to get
my car here in the next like month-ish
so that i can take those excursions and
have you know weekends there that way
when it's time for work and it's the
week days i don't feel like i'm missing
anything because i'm tired from work
anyway so don't want to take excursions
anyway so that's observations from
locations and whatnot now going on to
the people
i think everyone watching this has a
pretty
what's the word everyone kind of knows
what people say about la people
yes i think i said that correctly
everyone kind of has an idea or like of
the stereotype of la people what i'll
say to that what i'll say to that as it
says right now
you are not
wrong
so you're not right
but you're not
wrong
there is tons of that here
tons of the uh
social light
people
wanting you know the followers for the
gram for the tick tock their foodie
blogs over here and whatnot like i had
to tell someone
like hey are we are you gonna eat
anytime soon because the first i swear
like five minutes when the food came out
it was snapping and instagraming and
tick-tocking and here i am just trying
to eat my spaghetti and i'm like
i'm eating alone now i'm pretty much
eating alone like come on put your phone
away and i actually said that i was like
hey yo like come on and so yeah they put
their phone away and it was all good but
that's kind of the vibe and i think it's
also just the times that's what people
do especially with this parent-teacher
conference outside where it's like shoot
the best way for me to connect with
other people right now is online and so
i think there's a lot of factors going
into that but yes i have had to be like
that's not i feel like there's less of
that in downtown i feel like the people
here are very much more chill like very
down to earth chill kind of thinking of
like yeah new york type of people where
like like let me think what i don't i
don't remember the um burrows enough for
me to really
break it down to one type of burrow
maybe like the
gentrified bronx
yeah maybe like the gentrified bronx
where everyone's really just chill it's
not as much of a social light scene i
think it's partly because downtown is
less of the pretty and like
you know glistening spots of los angeles
for the glistening things you go to west
hollywood you go to beverly hills you'd
go to santa monica and so that's really
where you'll see more of that but like
downtown
that there's it's not as much like that
and so those people don't come here
so i think yeah if you are more chill
and relaxed and you want more down to
earth type of people and that earn more
experiences then downtown very much
might be the place for you now going
into dating before i go into it let me
just preface by saying i don't really
think i am the best person to ask
about this because i
don't really put myself out there i like
y'all i am stressed i just started a new
job i am new here like i am
very overwhelmed and so yeah putting
time to now
do all of that doesn't sound like a good
time to me but of the three minutes i
spent in that world
it kind of goes back to the type of
people again where like it seems like
everybody and their mama is in the media
and entertainment field and me working
in a media and entertainment company
right now
i don't really want
that
really in a potential partner going
through the dating space and everything
everyone's a producer or
a filmmaker a photographer an actor it's
like yo where are the teachers at where
are the social workers i am looking for
just
boring bob where is that person okay
maybe not boring but you know what i
mean where
is the gym teacher and so yes that's
everyone and their mama i think that's
really all i can say about that that and
yeah the whole thing like being into
appearances and being into all these
things like they're over
here with their designers and their
watches and their oh my gosh it's like
please i i cannot and so yeah i tapped
out of that real quick what i will say
though is la's definitely has a much
more diverse pool of people which is
much better than you know how it was
where i lived before and so there's a
lot more diverse pool of people but this
can kind of be like a good and bad thing
because yes there's more diversity so
you can find
what you're looking for
but
because there's a lot of people
it's gonna take a while to find that
thing it's gonna take a while to really
get that gym teacher
and because again there are so many
people there ends up being the mentality
of
but like you don't want to stick with
that person because what if there's
something better and there will always
be you know something better this is
always going to be someone more
good-looking someone you know more
exciting and so it makes it harder to
just set up shop somewhere now keep in
mind i'm just saying this off of what
you know friends and people have like
said to me i haven't really seen that
but then again i haven't really stuck
around in that scene to see it but i
that's what i have been told by the
people who have experienced it here so
yes that's really all i say about dating
hopefully you find what you want here if
you're looking to just take things light
and have fun and meet people then yeah
this is a great place to do that and
then lastly just general living and
activities and whatnot i really love la
for having pretty much everything and
anything i could want if i want the city
downtown l.a if i'm on the beach santa
monica if i want to hike there's all
these parks if i want to i don't even
know go and experience a whole nother
town then i can go up to san francisco
anything you want i truly can't think of
something i would want that couldn't get
right here and so that's something
that's really great and that's
definitely why
so many people are attracted to
california because you can truly get
anything you want
here you may have to look for it and
search for it like it's not going to
come to you on a silver platter likely
but you can find it and i think that's
something to be very excited about when
thinking about your move here and so no
there we go everybody my 30 day
reflection of la overall there's been
good times there's been bad times i've
had to get more accustomed with the
downtown life but as i go through more
and more days and walk around and all of
this i actually start loving a lot more
especially when it's nighttime and
there's the glistening lights and the
tall buildings and the really nice
summer air it's actually a really great
time but yeah i hope this was somewhat
helpful if you're thinking about moving
here please let me know down below where
you want to move please like and
subscribe and i'll see you all later bye